[Musica]
buonasera a tutti è una grande gioia
condividere con voi questa sera una mia
grande passione
l'automobile perché l'automobile è nuovo
l'automobile è sicuro l'automobile è
bello non mi sto sbagliando perché
quando l'automobile è stata inventata
alla fine dell'ottocento era considerato
un mobile semovente e quindi nelle
lingue come l'italiano il francese era
ho declinato al maschile le donne e poi
non tardarono ad impossessarsene già
all'inizio del novecento c'erano
numerose donne alla guida di veicoli
la regina margherita aveva la sua sede
dotata di tutti i confort e già
francesca mirabile mancuso di palermo
nel 1913 fu la prima donna ad avere la
patente di guida che era stata
introdotta l'anno prima per regio
decreto ma insomma uomini o donne
l'automobile è stata una grande
rivoluzione per tutta la società
l'automobile ha trasformato il modo di
vivere pensate cosa significava
all'inizio del secolo scorso poter avere
a disposizione un mezzo che consentiva
di coprire le distanze in tempi molto
molto inferiori rispetto agli anni prima
ad esempio in inghilterra fino al 1896
le vetture che circolavano per strada
dovevano essere precedute da un uomo di
corsa che agitava un drappo rosso per
allertare i passanti dell'arrivo
dell'automobile quindi immaginate cosa
doveva sembrare
avere sulla strada sulle strade questi
mezzi circolanti ancora oggi la landon
to brighton celebra il decreto legge che
superò quest'obbligo e finalmente le
vetture poterono circolare voleva dire
che giravano e 6 km e mezzo circa
allora la velocità di un uomo di corsa
ma le vetture già allora avevano un
potenziale molto molto più elevato
già nel 1896 una vettura elettrica
straordina è la landon to brighton che
si apre ancora oggi con la il rito del
lo strappo del del drappo rosso ma già
le corse cominciarono subito come ho
letto in un museo in america che ho
visitato di recente a philadelphia le
competizioni sono cominciate non appena
è stata costruita la seconda vettura la
corsa la sfida il senso del superare
superare se stessi e superare gli altri
un incredibile corsa verso l'innovazione
e già dicevo nel 1899 una vettura
elettrica la jam e contanti si chiamava
superò i 100 chilometri all'ora
i 105 chilometri all'ora e vinse la gara
del chilometro lanciato un'altra gara
straordinaria fu vinta dalla itala nel
1907 che coprì la distanza impensabile
di 60mila chilometri da pechino a parigi
e arrivò prima erano in cinque
concorrenti ma superò i concorrenti di
una settimana di anticipo di una
settimana sono imprese straordinarie
dovete immaginare davvero il senso di
libertà di possibilità incredibile che
ha portato ad automobili e poi
finalmente la diatriba se fosse uomo
donna fu superato abbastanza
brillantemente da uno che di donne ne
aveva una certa esperienza gabriele
d'annunzio che nel 1926 in una sua
lettera all'avvocato agnelli che gli
aveva donato
una fiat 509 cabriolet e che lui aveva
testato per ringraziarlo nel
ringraziarlo egli scrisse anche che
quella sortiva ogni dubbio
l'automobile è femmina e quindi da
allora questa è stata un'altra vittoria
del gentil sesso ma diciamo che oggi
l'automobile ci fa vivere l'esperienza è
tutt'altro modo oggi fa parte della vita
quotidiana di tutti noi
il percepito dell'automobile non è più
quello del senso di realizzazione di noi
stessi non so per quanto di quanti di
voi alla mattina a dover prendere l'auto
mettersi in coda nel traffico possa
essere ancora un emozione come lo era
nei primi anni del secolo scorso e tutto
sommato crea anche tanti problemi
inquinamento traffico ma dobbiamo anche
considerare che le città di oggi sono
state costruite le vetture girano su
strade che una volta erano percorse solo
da cavalli quindi per questo ci troviamo
in questa situazione ma anche per i
giovani
l'automobile non è più non rappresenta
più quel senso di emancipazione e di
indipendenza di libertà che
rappresentava per noi questa è la 500
che io guidavo con orgoglio a 18 anni
era un pensiero irrinunciabile prendere
la patente immediatamente compiuti i 18
anni per poter guidare poter spostarsi
da da castrocaro dove vivevo a forlì
andare a scuola da sola essere
indipendente oggi per i giovani non è
più così hanno altre ambizioni altre
aspirazioni possono comunicare e
muoversi in mille altri modi
queste sono le strade in cui siamo
costretti a a circolare ma devo dire che
io penso che l'automobile e la sua
storia non siano affatto finiti penso
che l'automobile troverà la strada per
superare queste difficoltà perché penso
che ancora sia irrinunciabile il diritto
il bisogno dell'uomo di muoversi
liberamente l'automobile è il mezzo
personale di mobilità per eccellenza
quindi credo che tutto lo studio
l'innovazione che si sta portando avanti
comunque e consentirà di conservare
l'automobile come un bene futuro e oggi
si stanno progettando città intere dove
le veicoli a guida autonoma potranno
circolare potranno essere connessi
potranno sviluppare l'intelligenza
artificiale
quindi ha una storia tutt'altro che
finita
c'è la racconteranno certo i fatti anche
recenti dimostrano che c'è ancora strada
da fare per l'automobile ma la direzione
è questa però ecco io penso che non sia
solo diciamo una sfida di tipo
tecnologico penso che sia anche
importante trovare il modo di collegare
la storia il passato le soluzioni che
già allora si pensavano al presente e al
futuro penso che sia importante che ci
sia forse un luogo in cui questo possa
venire come dice ora un pamuk far sì che
il tempo di 20 spazio e quindi un museo
anche un museo dell'automobile può avere
un ruolo nel nell'evoluzione della
storia dell'automobile
quindi un museo che non sia una raccolta
di cimeli perché tutto sommato
l'automobile non è del passato
l'automobile è presente tuttora oggi
sulle strade sulle piste nei centri di
innovazione sviluppo si continua a
studiare a progettare nuove soluzioni
quindi il museo deve diventare un luogo
in cui si dibatte si discute si
condividono idee e soluzioni
ci sono già molti musei dell'automobile
ci sono musei di marca nel museo ferrari
museo alfa romeo museo mercedes
forse ce ne sono tanti innumerevoli nel
mondo ci sono collezioni pubbliche e
private che sono state raccolte nel
tempo con grande passione e con la
voglia di condividere con altri in
questa passione ma oggi per un museo non
basta mostrare bisogna creare dei
collegamenti delle emozioni per attirare
i visitatori e per coinvolgerli sul
futuro è un museo oggi questo lo può
fare in tanti modi con tante iniziative
indirizzate diverse tipologie di
visitatori per esempio a chi è più
anziano si possono raccontare le storie
delle vetture del passato di quando loro
erano giovani la giulietta sprint della
lancia primi a quelli dei loro genitori
ci possono essere i giovani da
coinvolgere intanto iniziative per
esempio lo sport oi viaggi ci possono
essere laboratori didattici ci possono
essere
letture legate ai film perché a per
senato di cinema quindi tante storie da
raccontare ma soprattutto per i giovani
è importante poterli coinvolgere in modo
da poter attraverso l'automobile sognare
e inventarsi e qualificarsi per un
futuro migliore
perché io penso che la dove si studia si
lavora sia importante farlo con una
finalità superiore che sia quello di
portare la storia alle generazioni
future
e non importa se sono uomini o donne c'è
bisogno dell'energia di tutti per
migliorarsi e portare a un futuro
migliore in un museo che non sia un
luogo dove si custodiscono le ceneri ma
dove si coltivano le braci grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]